so rich hill all set to go to work
here is vlad guerrero jr
that's a light shot caught by joy
they're going to get the double play oh
what a shot and what a catch by joy to
get the unassisted double play at first
base
take a look at that line shot the grab
by joy down there robby ray's had a
great start 336 earned run average set
119 punch outs this season
one juke fighter foul tip hang held onto
by danny jensen the first strikeout of
the ball game for ronnie ray and with
one out nobody on te oscar hernandez
oh there's strike three call
and there's one at bat ender
that breaking ball that tried to get to
the corner yep and this is tough on
hernandez because that pitch starts off
the plate away it actually ends up off
the plate away
and mejia able to gather that ball in
and present it very well hernandez like
you've got to be kidding me andy
rosarina hitting just 217 over his last
13 games as they throw three in a row
does he challenge him there's a high
fastball he gets to swing into miss
second strikeout for robbie ray one down
here in the second that pitch right
there should tell robbie that he's got a
pretty good fastball out of his wind he
delivers to bruhan strike three call
95 on the other half and that's his
third strikeout g-man choi he dropped
down to the seventh spot in the batting
order
called strike three how about a
three-pitch strikeout for robbie ray
he strikes out the side he has four
strikeouts through two innings robbie
ray's dealing early on
danny jansen now
with a one-two count
breaking ball hit high and deep to left
get up ball get out of here gone danny
jensen goes deep
his fourth home run of the season on a
high breaking ball and the blue jays
have broken on top
one to nothing let that thing break here
it comes and now let it go throw that
change up 10 or 12 times you're going to
have them thinking about it
swinging a miss phillips strikes up
that's five strikeouts through two and
two thirds for robby ray first time
through the order five strikeouts with
the nine spots in the batting order the
one-two pitch
swinging a miss got him on a nice off
speed
breaking pitches springer swung right
through it
for strike one
rush fleming another left-hander with a
finesse type style that ball is off the
glove of yandy diaz hard hit by t oscar
hernandez
that'll be a hit for t oscar comes with
one out here in the fourth big
opportunity for espana
and he hits it through the right side
for a run for sure they're going to stop
the runner at third guerrilla hernandez
comes in to score espanol with another
rbi that'll give him 10. cavendish
runners into quarters one out
it's this ball deep into center field
that's going to score a run
guriel tagging in third he'll come in
the score espinal tries to go to second
and he is in there yeah espanol they
made a close play and kind of
smooths out that left-handed swing is
there a strike three called in a
beautifully placed
94 mile an hour fastball i think that's
the other thing that water is going to
learn here and better learn quickly is
that
big league pitchers know how to make
that pitch well now the one-two pitch
swing gonna miss same thing as last time
fastball up and away and he went chasing
95 that's the seventh strikeout now for
ray this g-man sure he was called out on
strikes his first time i probably raised
struck him out on three pitches
choo choo pitch
swinging a miss another strikeout for
robbie ray he's mowing him down through
five innings
tampa bay doesn't have a base hit the
way he has thrown his fastball has been
outstanding and his breaking ball has
been good but more importantly it's
where he's throwing it he is
putting it on the corner he's throwing
it up in the strike zone if he needs to
his command and control has been
outstanding so far
and it's it's more than just hey here's
my fastball he's got the great fastball
but he's got great command also today
and right now the rays haven't even come
close to getting a hit
as we are
nearing the second week of july and
robbie ray strikes out another that's
nine strikeouts as mahir goes down for
his first strike out of the afternoon
here's brett phillips
oh strike three phillips
caught looking
that's ten strikeouts now through five
and two thirds for robbie ray
franco has struck out he was called out
on strikes in the fourth
call strike tree right at the knees
franco thought it was low but it looked
like it had plenty of the strength zone
yes it did robbie remembers the home run
that he gave up the franco the last time
these two teams met it was on a slider
and he said i am not throwing him
another slide or two strikes right at
the knees yes as we mentioned the only
base runner for
tampa bay this afternoon
and this ball is going to be a ball at
the top of the fence that fan reached
over
and made contact with the baseball and
the question will be whether or not that
was over the fence yandy diaz thinking
it might have been over the fence and
then it's probably going to get a review
as we speak it is a double
and the fan reaches over and it looks
like it is going to be short of going
out of the ballpark he leaned over and
caught him below that program fence and
made contact right there and that wasn't
going to go out of the ballpark but it's
the first hit of the game is the
performance put together by robbie ray
and i'll tell you it started early and
often was very very good with that
fastball and slider combo and that's
really what he stuck with all game long
the only guy that had any success off of
him was yandy diaz he was able to earn a
two out walk in the first inning of
course he got the only hit the double in
the seventh right there francisco here
the switch it didn't catch him two two
pitches swung in and lifted in the air
foul territory first base side into the
bullpen area giving chase as the right
fielder hernandez and he runs it down
to retire the side nice play by
oscar hernandez
here's santiago espinal
one and two to espana
he rips it up the middle another base
hit half a day
santiago espinal a three hit game he has
half of the blue jays hits today
a terrific
game he has had to go into the all-star
break
get on top of that high fast balls
here's brandon lau you struck out slide
to right and fouled the first
[Applause]
high shot back into deep center that
ball's got carrie gone
home run for now
raids are on the board home run number
21 for brandon wow
yeah that's a big out for toronto here's
yondi diaz he singles into right on the
first pitch and the raves are going to
get the potential tying run
to the plate then that's meadow's turn
once again an 02 pitch
and once again meadows fouls it off
long run for bow he's got room he's
going to make the catch settle in the
ball game
move as [ __ ] with a long run playing in
the shift and jordan romano
closes out the race abuja salvaged the
final game of this three-game series as
they win it
3-1 good way to go into the all-star
break